Which ones did you think,
David, and why?
>> So for learning a script, I said that
five of the things we've talked about so
far would really help
an agent learn a script.
So we've seen in the past
that semantic networks and
frames are representationally
equivalent.
We saw that when we put the raven's
progressive matrices problems
in terms of first semantic networks and
then converted them to frames.
Frames, as we've seen, are very useful
for storing the type of information
necessary to construct
a thorough script.
And if semantic networks
are representationally equivalent,
then we can also imagine a script
composed of semantic networks instead.
To skip the middle couple for a second,
I can imagine incremental concept
learning to be very important
to learning scripts.
We can an imagine an AI agent
acting in the world and
encountering multiple events everyday,
and even to start to kind of develop
a categorization scheme for
those different experiences.
So for example, that agent might learn
that if I'm developing a script for
fast food, whether or not I see a
McDonald's logo or a Wendy's logo when I
walk in, is not necessarily
important to which script I run.
But whether or not I see a counter
with cashiers behind it or
a hostess waiting to see me,
is important.
So that way, an agent can use
incremental concept learning to learn
the difference, for example, a fast
food script and a fine dining script.
So Ashok discussed before, planning
happens when an agent has an initial
state and a goal state and figures
out how to navigate between the two.
Once they figured out that plan for
navigating between that initial
state and that goal state,
that then becomes a script that could be
transferred to a new similar situation
without having to completely
re-plan the route from scratch.
And finally common sense reasoning helps
the agent out because it gives the agent
a kind of a language within which to
learn the script in the first place.
It can learn a script within this
language of primitive actions that
it understands and then can use those to
make sense of new and novel situations.
Production systems and learning by
recording cases don't really apply as
much to scripts because they both
involve representations at a very
different level of abstraction,
at a very low level of abstraction.
With learning by recording cases,
we tend to stick with the cases,
whereas scripts we have
an abstraction over them.
And production systems are more like
atoms of knowledge representation
instead of molecules or compounds
like we deal with with scripts.
>> That's good, David.
I may add, one of the things
regarding the semantic networks.
Recall that when we
discussed semantic networks,
we had considered how we could use
semantic networks to interpret stories.
We'll use this same example.
Ashok wanted to become rich.
He got a gun.
And we said that inside a semantic
network the notes that correspond to
Ashok wanted rich and gun get activated.
And the activation spread from there and
there's a path that formed a spare
semantic network that path is the
interpretation of this particular story.
In a sense a script is that part.
>> Of course if you think you see a
connection between production systems or
learning by recording cases and
scripts that I haven't seen.
Or if you think the connection
between the other topics and
scripts isn't quite as
close as I've described,
feel free to head over to our forums and
we'll discuss it there.